sometimes y'all you love them and I love
it
put your hands together hey you know
what I was thinking about putting out a
comedy written comedy you've been a
singer I shake dancer ha it's real hard
to break him I'll do whatever it takes
you need I come up with a new character
dolomite it's my name and [ __ ] up
[ __ ] it's my game you look like
a pimp it's all pretend I just created a
character future pull own it oh yes
right whatever it takes I'm ready to do
it
I got to be totally outrageous it's
filthy you've got a product here that
you can't sell or promote on my life
give them and tell them you know Rudy
sometimes our dreams just don't come
true
I'm a and slam a door in my face I just
found another door I want the world of
know I exist
this ain't funny and it ain't no
brothers in it either if I get up in
that light with my own movie at the
everywhere all at once
let's bring dolomite to the screen the
actors we hire you're a big dohyo than
their dough here I'm offering you a role
in my new motion picture you think you
can just walk up here and hire me
no what if we let you direct in
storytelling it's always best to write
what you know ain't nothing to talk
about my personal life
I deal with tonight night club owners
and mobsters lots of pimps and kungfu do
you know karate no but I'm a fast
learner I can earn me a month
[Music]
give it to me to wait tonight he could
be a sex machine
what planet justice get on this thing
flops you're gonna be working for free
for the rest of your life I'm so
grateful but what you did for me cuz I
never seen nobody that looks like me now
update on that big screen
god damn dolomite Great Khan of heaven
good was it good a shame
[Music]
you
you